لقد كانت لديك النسخة المصغّرة بين يديك
على مدار الـ 48 ساعة الماضية. لقد شاهدت
الـ trap score. وشعرت كيف يكون
امتلاك درع حقيقي. لكن بينما أنت
تراقب الـ score، كانت الحيتان
تتطور بالفعل. النسخة المصغّرة
تريك الباب، لكن البروتوكول الكامل
يُريك الغرفة بأكملها.
في هذه اللحظة، خوارزميات المؤسسات
تنسج إشارات مزيفة لإشعال
الـ FOMO لديك. وعندما تُغلق الفخاخ، قد لا
يكفي الدرع المصغّر. أنت بحاجة إلى
حزمة الذكاء البصري الكاملة. أربعة محرّكات
ذكاء اصطناعي: Grok وGPT وGemini و
CryptoQuant تعمل بتناغم. تتبّع
الحيتان لحظة بلحظة، فلاتر معنويات،
واتخاذ قرار خلال 3 ثوانٍ. هذا ليس
تداولًا عاديًا، بل ميزة غير عادلة.
وللاحتفال بمدافعينا الجدد،
نفتح حملة البروتوكول. ولـ
أول 50 شخصًا فقط، يمكنك فتح
كل شيء بخصم 50%. إنها حماية
مؤسسية كاملة بأقل من
دولار واحد يوميًا. ولكن عندما تُحجز
هذه الـ 50 مقعدًا، سينتهي الرابط و
سيتضاعف السعر. لا تترك رأس مالك
للحظ. قم بترقية بروتوكول
الدفاع الخاص بك. استخدم الرمز defend50 عند الدفع
الآن. مرحبًا بك في الأكاديمية الكاملة.
لنربح معًا.